she's here I'm here this is Michele
Michele she's left you no time the
strong light seen on run like that so
what do you think of the house so far I
think it's delicious except they have
terrible food and when I open the fridge
I smell curry and I'm not being
stereotypical it really smells like that
and I know because there's curry in
there
this isn't that grilled chisel yep and
Mowat sizzle so I need something that
good yes I cleaned them the house before
you oh I cleaned it up the bad guy and
then mess it up I cleaned up the house
before you got here thank you
I packed my entire life into a suitcase
in a duffel bag
that's my movie isn't it no I I wouldn't
know I don't watch a lot of movies and
now I'm gonna change that this week I
brought everything that I own including
my entire friends collection that is art
movies though as a TV show what do you
think of the dog clip both kill ya he's
even cuter than the dog that almost bit
my lip off nose little yeah well it was
a beagle that's the only reason I
compare them oh I wouldn't know
I'm yeah I'm not a dog person well it
wasn't my dog so have you been watching
the vlogs mm-hmm I really like a Kanye
West or what everyone thinks I need you
to hurry up now I can't right now so
what are your plans for the dog tomorrow
I'm gonna walk him in the morning yes I
I can walk in I've walked him one night
no today yes but I put him out on the
dog leash outside for a long time that's
nice of you
he has fleas I know he ties I really
think he has fleas I'm getting these
little red bumps on my leg I didn't come
here with scabies
so where did the wine go how's the wine
gone